so Jacqueline Kirk who you were
convicted for his arrest came more than
20 years after his brutal attack he's
died as a result of the injuries that
she's sustained in the assault which you
committed upon her
Stephen Craig had already served 15
years for setting fire to his former
girlfriend now he faced a murder trial
it was in 1998 that Jacqueline Kirk was
attacked by Craig in Dolphin Square in
Western Superman he doused Jacqueline in
petrol for setting fire to her in an
imitation of a torture scene from the
Tarantino movie Reservoir Dogs
Jacqueline then 41 suffered Burns to 35
percent of her body including her face
neck torso and thighs
Jacqueline survived for more than two
decades but in 2019 she was rushed to
hospital in bath and died after a
swollen abdomen caused her diaphragm to
rupture the jury at Bristol Crown Court
found that injuries caused by Craig all
those years ago did play a part in her
death
is an unusual case that purely for the
amount of time that's passed so you know
between the injuries that Jackie
sustained back in 1998 and her death at
some 21 years and that is a significant
length of time so it's been really
important for us to find the right
medical experts to comment on the case
and give us the evidence we needed to
present to that jury Jacqueline's
daughter says it was important for her
mother not to live life as a victim we
are told 10 years
she probably wouldn't survive after 10
years so we made the most of it
and then
those 10 years came and went she
she had her 50th birthday which we never
thought was going to happen and then
time went on and she had her 60th
birthday she got to
um
see her son get married and have a child
got to see me get married and have
children
and that was a really really important
thing for all of us to have a mum for
those
for those life events
doctors who treated Jacqueline told the
court her scars did significantly impact
how they could treat her
Steven Craig now faces further time in
jail 24 years after his initial attack
damn Whited Sky News at Bristol Crown
Court